cette émission en fanfare une personne
dont vous êtes ultra fan le soleil de ma
vie le génie de la chanson
sébastien patate
suite
c'est une équipe
elie chouraqui voilà c'est ma soeur ma
toge camille chamoux que les cheveux
comédie tout prévu j'ai dû faire un
lissage brésilien en urgence sinon je
vais vous dire que ça a répété les mains
écoutez je suis venu vous voir parce que
c'est la dernière mais vous sentez très
fort je vais vous expliquer un petit
détail de ma vie en ce moment je suis en
petite tournée
ce qui fait que je ne peux pas laver mon
costume du coup j'ai obligé de rajouter
du brut de fabergé sa cocotte face à
vous si vous savez
mais je vous garantie un truc c'est que
l'odeur du parfum est beaucoup mieux que
si j'en avais pas bien est-ce qu'on va
jouer on va pas jouer juste devant vous
faire une petite chanson comme sa
défense
oui vous savez ici on a fait en valent à
[ __ ] au fond malheureusement
malheureusement s'est fait déborder
rouillé par ces connards de teutons
voilà les et là je vous jure je lisais
là ça passe pas ça ne passe pas du coup
la maison dit ma bulle en catastrophe
dit il faut que tu chantes avec tu
changes ta chanson ouais du coup j'ai
été obligé d'écrire ça dans la langue de
goethe ou voilà d'accord mais ça vite
fait en en allemand ou alors je peux
vous dire que ce n'était pas une partie
de plaisir incroyable parce que déjà
avec leurs sandalettes et leur blesse il
ya un gouffre tout l'été mais l'allemand
je veux dire que la chaîne espère que
personnellement dans la salle non non
non non je ne claque alors je vous faire
cette petite version et on va terminer
là dessus les forçant à meyrin une
peut-être une petite larmichette
pourquoi pas finalement c'est parce
qu'il fait le plus troublant c'est
ensemble je vous rappelle
sébastien batoche est dans les bacs
lacy swing berba in rio où depuis 6 ou
10 0 des birkenstock avec les
chaussettes volkswagen
un joueur français
il joue vd recours à chapeau un coût
unitaire cats ont un coût et des repos
merde j'ai pas fais du litre non
magiciens mais crois moi on va pas
passer pour des merguez parce qu'on à
l'euro 2016
au fond on va la foule en
fond si on est bon et qu'on descend du
bus on va la [ __ ] au fond aller tous
ensemble on va la [ __ ] uza
sanofi
sans toi le teuton écart que les cuisses
pour marquer un but
on va là foutrais fond
allez tous ensemble pour un lapin papa
la part
et karim au caire comme eva tissot
je suis
soit
taffin cour d'honneur de l'hôtel
national de
raymond légale et du travail le sceau de
rassurer
sur hadji
sébastien batoche
les souvenirs
whissell
on
vous
au fond le gardien écarté les cuisses
qu'on marque un but
marcoux
ah l'amour